So how do we learn to describe the world within our skin? What's going on?
Well, we learn, through trial and error, experience, and reinforcement. So,
here's an example. My niece, Sophia was about six years old. And we were at the
airport, and she was going to fly to Switzerland for the summer to see her
Grammy. And she said, aunt Sue, my tummy feels funny. And I said oh, honey
those are called butterflies, you're just nervous about flying. She said no it,
it doesn't feel right. It kind of hurts. I said no, no. That's just called
nervousness or anxiousness. And she kept telling that something was wrong, and
I was trying to describe it as excitement, as anxiousness. And it turns out
that when they got to Switzerland, my brother called me, and Sophia actually
was vomiting the entire way. so, it turns out that Aunt Sue was wrong. she
wasn't anxious, she wasn't nervous, she actually had some type of stomach bug.
But that's an example of me as an adult, trying to teach a child about what's
going on inside their skin. So, besides experiencing pain or an upset stomach,
how do we describe feelings such as love or passion? There's a lot of
literature out there on love and passion. But until you experience it, it's
very difficult to describe.